Ich habe den Untertitel erweitert, um meine
Herangehensweise an Fisch widerzuspiegeln, also ist es
Plato-Fotze und weidet sich an der Teamarbeit
des Geistes, und ich beginne mit einem Zitat
von Freud, das Freud zugeschrieben wird, aber
niemand konnte es bei Freud finden,
es ist ständig  obwohl unter
Freuds Namen Pseudo-Freud verwendet, wo immer ich
hingehe, fand ich einen Dichter vor
mir. Meine Gesprächsorte fixierten einen nachhaltigen
Rückgriff auf den Triebbegriff in
den historischen und systematischen Kontext des
platonischen und kantischen Denkens über die
Psychopolitik des Abschnitts Selbstbestimmung  man
bereitet büchsen und gesichter vor, denkt über
die einheit und funktionalität des verstandes
in spiegeln von wunsch und willen nach,
wendet sich aber platos poetischem vergleich
der seelenanordnung und betriebsart
zu einem gespann von pferden mit postcharakter zu
, die von einem ernsthaft herausgeforderten getrieben werden
Wagenlenker-Abschnitt 2 befasst sich zunächst
mit der Widerlegung der zweifachen
irrationalen und rationalen Modi des
praktischen Verstandes, der Fähigkeit des Begehrens und der
verwandten Co  Die Konzeption der zweifachen
Willensfreiheit als willkürliche Wahl und
gesetzgeberische Autonomie und verfolgt dann die
Eignungsaneignung des Konzepts des
Triebs, um die dynamische
Struktur und Funktionalität des Geistes zu beschreiben,
multiple und konkurrierende Triebe, einschließlich
des natürlichen Triebs, des reinen Triebs und des
gemischten oder ethischen Triebs  In Anlehnung an
Platons pferdeartige Analogie für das geistige
Regime der Selbstverwaltung baut der Vortrag auf
der etymologischen Identität des deutschen
Begriffs Trip und seinem englischen Äquivalent
Drive auf, um sicherzustellen, dass der deutsche Trip
nicht das erweiterte semantische Feld
des englischen Drive teilt, das den einschließt
Fahrzeughandhabung von Tieren wie beim
Fahren eines Pferdegespanns, außerdem beim
Zugreifen auf die plethorische Modellierung
des Geistes.
Rock achtet genau auf den bürgerlichen
oder politischen Ursprung und Horizont eines
Großteils der ethischen oder allgemein praktischen
Konzeptualisierung, die von Pfister und
seinem Hauptvorläufer Kant verwendet wurde  zum Erfassen
der komplexen und widersprüchlichen Einheit und
Funktionsweise o  f the mind section 1
dann das Zitat des alten Hippodroms Eric
aus Platon, zu Beginn ist unser
Fahrer für ein Paar Pferde verantwortlich, das
zweite seiner Pferde ist schön
und gut und aus der gleichen Sorte,
während das andere das Gegenteil ist und hat
der gegensätzlichen Blutlinie bedeutet dies
, dass das Wagenfahren in unserem
Fall zwangsläufig eine peinlich
schwierige Fußarbeit ist, wenn man über
die mannigfaltigen Arten der Sinngebung von Begriffen
nachdenkt, die Kant in § 59
der mit der Aufklärung der Schönheit beladenen Kritik der Urteilskraft bedenkt  als
Symbol der Moral bemerkt, dass die
Sprache voller indirekter Darstellungen
nach einer Analogie ist,
wodurch der Ausdruck nicht
das eigentliche Schema des Begriffs enthält, sondern
nur ein Symbol für die Reflexion und
natürlich die logische Analogiebeziehung
zwischen zwei Begriffen  der Bedeutung,
von denen sich nur eine auf einen sinnlichen Gegenstand bezieht,
während die andere einen Gegenstand des
Denkens bezeichnet, führt das ein  sprachliche
Mittel der Metapher und Tropen als
Schlüsselmittel für das Denken dessen,
was mündlich nicht sinnlich gemacht
werden kann, sich aber als unverzichtbarer
Teil unserer intellektuellen und moralischen
Ökonomie erweisen könnte, so Kant, ist unser Diskurs,
einschließlich des physischen Diskurses,
mit solchen metaphorischen analogischen oder beladen
symbolische Mittel, die jeweils
einzeln ausgetauscht und
verändert werden können, die aber generisch und
kollektiv betrachtet die
unverzichtbaren Werkzeuge des
Redens und Denkens sind  Die
ebenso weit gefasste Naturphilosophie
Can't selbst gibt das Beispiel einer
Handmühle,
die den modernen
absolutistischen Staat analog symbolisch oder tropisch wiedergibt, nur um ihn unmittelbar
80 völlig abwechselnd
konstituierten quasi-republikanischen Staaten gegenüberzustellen, die
von dem regiert werden, was er intrinsisch Bevölkerung nennt  r
Gesetze, die mit einem lebenden Körper oder Organismus verglichen werden,
ein Konzept, das im Mittelpunkt
der dritten Kritik des zweiten Teils über die
theologische Urteilskraft steht, zu dem
der betreffende Abschnitt 59 über die
Symbolik fast den Übergang bildet,
das Zählgerät der symbolischen
Repräsentation im Allgemeinen und  insbesondere der
philosophischen symbolik
hat eine bemerkenswerte geschichte ein
paradigmatisches exemplar des lehrers ist
platons erweiterte analogie zwischen der
seele und der stadt in der republik freilich unterscheiden
sich hier symbolisierende
und symbolisierte begriffe nicht
dadurch, dass sie sinnvoll
bzw. verständlich sind
beide Domänen, die psychologische
und die politologische, unser Intellektueller,
aber dies ist auch der Fall bei Dosen, die
den despotischen
und den republikanischen Lyridenstaat kontrastieren,
und bei vielen anderen Fällen einer zurückhaltenden
Khmer-Truppe, die ein Feld von Symbolen zeichnete, das
bereits selbst stark
von Non geprägt war  sinnvolle Begriffe und Konzepte der
erweiterten psychopolitischen Anal  ogie,
die Platons Republik ist, hat viel
späteres Denken über die Normen und
Lebensformen in Stadt und Staat beeinflusst.
Besonders einflussreich war
Platons Bild der quasi politischen
Einrichtung der Seele anhand der
drei Stände, die Sokrates'
ideale Stadt ausmachen  stellen fest, dass
der Schwerpunkt der Analogie
die Einheit der Psyche war und die Einheit
des Polnischen bzw. weglässt, dass es sich um
analoge Differenzierungen in psychische
und politische Kräfte, Kräfte oder
Fähigkeiten handelt, insbesondere wurde
allgegenwärtig von den Teilen der
Seele in Analogie gesprochen  Trotz der politischen Teilung der Stadtstaaten ist
Platon selbst
eher unschuldig,
wenn er offen eine mariya-logische Sprache verwendet, anstatt es
vorzuziehen, über verschiedene Arten
oder verschiedene Arten der Seele zu
sprechen
Interpretationen der
Republik ist umso beunruhigender angesichts
Platons Sokrates Azure Auswurf der
Seelen zusammengesetzte Natur im Phaedo,
wo es um die Unsterblichkeit der Seele geht,
wie Plato und Sokrates in diesem Dialog argumentieren, der
ungefähr
gleichzeitig mit der Republik betrachtet wird,
was aus Teilen besteht, die der
Zersetzung in ihre Teile unterliegen und
die Gefahr laufen, ihre Einheit und
damit Identität zu verlieren  der entscheidende Moment des
drohenden Zerfalls der Seelen ist
der Tod und die darauf folgende Zersetzung
des menschlichen Körpers. Ein weiteres Merkmal, das
die Leser von Plato
und Vergangenheit und Gegenwart verwirrte, ist die
Identifizierung der Teile, der Art
oder der Funktionen, aus denen die Seele besteht
wie die Stadt in der Republik, denn
hier fügt Platon bekanntermaßen zwischen den
intelligenten und den appetitlichen Regionen des
Körpers, dem Physischen sowie dem Körper,
das Logistische und das
Epigenetische ein, wie er es oft übersetzt als die
jähzornige Modalität innerhalb der Seele und
der Stadt bezeichnet
Temperament zu muy des außerdem in seiner
mittleren Position auf halbem Weg zwischen dem
Kopf und dem  Underbelly
Chestie Tomas wird von
einem seiner anatomischen Nachbarn beeinflusst
, der entweder den
logischen oder den unlogischen Regionen Impulse oder Antrieb verleiht, die
Richtungen oder Orientierungen
der Seele und des Stadtstaates, um sicher zu sein,
dass für Platon Sokrates die zweideutige
Position von Tomas ist
zugunsten der Herrschaft des Rationalen
über das Irrationale durch das
traumatische Energieelement eindeutig gemacht werden,
das als Hilfskraft dienen soll, um
das Regime der Vernunft zu
sichern, das dieser hellen und gerechten Ordnung der
psychischen und politischen Dinge die
Einheit der Seele und des Politischen verwehrt  die Einheit der
Stadt von gewaltsamer Auflösung bedroht ist
unter dem Deckmantel des
Bürgerkriegs, um nicht zu sagen Bürgerkriegsstatus, und sein psychisches
Äquivalent, die exegetischen Minutien,
die Teile und Arten betreffen,
bietet jedoch einen
strategisch begrenzten Ausblick auf die
Beziehung zwischen den drei Hauptelementen
von  die seele und die stadt gleichermaßen normativ
betrachtet ist der logische oder rationale
teil die regel  Der Appellativ muss
beherrscht werden und die thematische Mitte soll dafür
sorgen, dass die Gründe über die
Begierden herrschen, da in der Republik die
Politik der Seele eng an die
Plato-Psychologie der Stadtpolitik angelehnt ist und ihre
eingebettete Ethik auch die
politische Perspektive des Werks imitiert, die
erscheinen muss  ausgesprochen illiberal
gegenüber modernen
Staatskonzepten von Hobbes und Locke
durch Motive, die auch bis zu
Humboldt reichen, um nur die Ur- und
Freiliberalen unter ihnen zu nennen, braucht man
der von Karl
Popper im Gefolge vertretenen Auffassung nicht anzuhängen
Totalitarismus des 20. Jahrhunderts auf der äußersten Linken wie
auch auf der Rechten, dass Platon
zu den Feinden der offenen Gesellschaft gezählt werden muss, um
den Anachronismus Platons in der
modernen politischen Welt der Welt der
Volkssouveränität, der liberalen Demokratie
und der freien Marktwirtschaft zumindest in der Welt der Volkssouveränität wahrzunehmen
Westliche oder westliche Teile der
heutigen Welt
haben sicherlich auch Versuche unternommen, sie
wiederzufinden  Retten oder stellen Sie das Ansehen
von Platons
Öffentlichkeit wieder her, wie zum Beispiel Cancer Temp, um
die platonische Republik durch die Idee
einer staatsbürgerlich kompatiblen individuellen
Freiheit im Staat qua Commonwealth oder
Haggards Versuch neu zu definieren, der später von der Notwendigkeit nachgeahmt wurde
, die Republik als idealtypische
Darstellung griechischer politischer Ethik zu lesen
zumindest von Platon im
Moment seiner
von den vereinten Kräften der athenischen Demokratie herbeigeführten
pseudophilosophischen Sophistik und des postsophokanischen europäischen
Experimentaltheaters wiederbelebt, aber es sind nicht nur
die antiken politischen und ethischen Werte
, die im Zusammenhang unbehaglich zu stehen scheinen
des modernen politischen und ethischen Lebens
zusammen mit seiner philosophischen
Reflexion in weitgehend liberaler politischer
Philosophie von John Stuart Mill bis
Rawls und von der Traumakonstante - ha ha
Ramas genau die
von Plato vor etwa vierundzwanzig Jahrhunderten verwendete Begrifflichkeit
kann uns Idioten mit Schlüsselmerkmalen fremd erscheinen
die inzwischen marginal geworden sind,
wie To  mas oder umgekehrt Konzepte,
die bei Plato auffallend marginal sind, aber
in modernen Zeiten eine fast inflationäre Verbreitung erfahren haben, wie
Freiheit oder Liberty, um den Boden zu fassen
, um möglicherweise das zu überbrücken, was der letzte
so genannte böse weiße Graben ist
, der die Alten von den Idioten trennt aber
Auch wenn wir die Alten unter den
Idioten, die Konservativen, von den modernen
Modernen, den Liberalen, trennen, könnte es hilfreich sein,
sich einem anderen von Platons Dialogen zuzuwenden, um
ein anders gestaltetes Bild der
Seelen zu finden, die weniger
politisch angespannt und mehr auf
die dramatischen Ansichten des psychischen Lebens eingestellt sind
Diese alternative
Quelle für das Psychodrama, die
Ethik und Politik zugrunde liegt
, wird von den
Modernen kultiviert, wie sie im Theater von Shakespeare bis Epson und der modernen philosophischen Psychologie von Spinoza bis Freud kultiviert werden
der Liebe, sondern auch die
Beschäftigung mit einem mythischen  Eclair-Kritik am Schreiben
als zu starre und generell
geisttötende Kulturtechnik.
Philosophisch betrachtet ist eine Hauptbeschäftigung von
Feedern der richtige Platz des
Wahnsinns Mineas in einem hauptsächlich
von Vernunft und Selbstdisziplin geprägten Menschenleben, den
Wahnsinn zuzulassen, der
unter diesen Bedingungen sogar erforderlich ist  ist göttlicher Wahnsinn
Tia Manya in dieser Art von Merkmalen stellt
das richtige Verhältnis zwischen den
verschiedenen Faktoren und Merkmalen dar,
die die Seele in ihrem optimalen Betrieb ausmachen,
mittels eines detaillierten Bildes von Lee,
das von der klassischen Mythologie inspiriert und
von einem geschätzten zeitgenössischen
Zuschauer des Mythos informiert wurde  beinhaltet einen
geflügelten Wagenlenker, der einen Streitwagen fährt
, der von zwei geflügelten Pferden gezogen wird, von denen eines
als edel in Aussehen und
Charakter und von heller Farbe beschrieben wird, das andere
ist Bass und dunkel gefärbt
Zwischen Erde und Himmel schwebend
gibt es die Aufgabe des
Wagenlenkers  mit den Pferden umgehen,
sie auf Kurs halten und den oft gegensätzlichen Zug koordinieren, der
von den Pferden und dem Team ausgeübt wird. Die
von Plato Sokrates verwendete Bildsprache des Seelenwagens stützt sich
auf einen griechischen Mythos, der hauptsächlich in den
viel späteren literarischen Wiedergaben der
Perlenmetamorphose über den Streitwagen erhalten ist  Die
Sonne und der himmlische Feuerton-
Verkehrsunfall, der sich ereignete, als der Streitwagen
einst nicht vom Sonnengott
Helios selbst, sondern von Helios sterblichem Sohn gefahren wurde,
kämpfte weiter, dem es an Training
und Erfahrung mangelte, als der Sonnenwagen den Streitwagen nicht auf Kurs halten konnte
kam der Erde zu nahe und begann sie zu
versengen.
Helios musste mutig mit Allah kämpfen
, um die Erde zu retten. Es gibt
jedoch keinen Präzedenzfall im Kampf gegen den Mythos,
aber für die Vereinigung von
gegensätzlichen Pferden in einem Team in Platons
Mythos  Aber es gibt noch einen anderen Mythos, der
eine zweite und sogar eine dritte mythologische
Figur beinhaltet, die auch Kampf auf Bestimmung genannt
wird  Beispiel „Fight on“ ist der Sohn der
Göttin der Morgenröte, ein „us the rose fingered
one“ in Homers aktueller Phrase, und das
zweite Beispiel „fight on“ ist der Name
eines der beiden Pferde der Erben und ihres
Streitwagens, des anderen Pferdes eines Teams,
das Laternenpfahl genannt wird  was bedeutet, glänzen, so glänzen
und glänzen in einer Null-Verdopplung von
Mythen. Yas Streitwagen steigt jeden
Morgen vor Sonnenaufgang den Himmel hinauf, was dann
wiederum von Helios in seinem eigenen
Streitwagen ausgeführt wird, verglichen mit Helios Streitwagen, jetzt ist
der von Ihnen gefahrene Wagen passender
als der Hintergrund  des platonischen Mythos
für Ohrenwagen wird von zwei Pferden gezogen,
im Gegensatz zu den vier Pferden, die vom Streitwagen des Sonnengottes gezogen werden,
außerdem neigen bildliche Darstellungen dazu,
uns in ihrem zweispännigen Streitwagen
mit Flügeln auf allen drei Figuren darzustellen. MINIX
staatliche Antiquitätensammlung auf der
Konex  Plots gleich um die Ecke von
hier hat ein schönes Exemplar des Motivs
Ich denke, das ist die Klarheit, die wir haben,
aber Sie können sehen, dass es ein Ausschnitt aus
Süditalien ist  Im späten 5. Jahrhundert
v. Chr. Der andere Kontext, der
Platons Entwurf des Seelenwagens beeinflusst, ist
der tatsächliche Einsatz des Streitwagens in
der griechischen Kultur der späten Bronzezeit, insbesondere
in der Kriegsführung, aber eher für den Transport zum
Schlachtfeld als für tatsächliche Fahrzeugkämpfe
später im griechischen Militär
Konfrontation mit Asien erst die
Perserkriege und dann in Alexanders
Asienfeldzügen erwiesen sich die hellenischen Hopliten als
schwerbewaffnete Fußsoldaten mit langem
Lance in Formationsphalanx agierenden Formationsphalanx
als überlegen gegenüber der feindlichen Formation
von Streitwagen, obwohl der
Streitwagen zu einem
Sportgerät geworden war  bei Olympischen und anderen
panhellenischen Spielen, aber der aristokratische
und kriegerische Stammbaum des Streitwagens
überlebte im Wagenrennen, da es die
teuerste Sportdisziplin ist, an der man
sich beteiligen kann. Typischerweise wurde der Streitwagen nicht
einmal vom Besitzer des Streitwagens
und seinem Pferdegespann gefahren, sondern von a  angeheuerten
Athleten ging der Preis noch immer an
den Teambesitzer wie in der heutigen Zeit  world of
equine bestreitet die Bedeutung und das
aufschlussreiche Potenzial des griechischen
kulturellen Hintergrunds im Streitwagenfahren
für Platons
neomythischen Seelenwagen, wird in einer
anderen Antike aus dem 5. Jahrhundert
v
Aufgrund seiner ursprünglichen Funktion als
Widmungsstatue in Delphi gehört er zu den
wenigen antiken
griechischen Bronzen, die noch original erhalten sind,
eher als durch spätere römische
meist Marmorkopien bekannt ist. Die Statue ist eine
lebensgroße, wenn nicht sogar etwas größere 1,8
Meter darstellende Statue  der jugendliche
Wagenlenker, wie er sich auf dem
Streitwagen mit den beiden Pferden präsentiert, die
jetzt den Zuschauern des Rennens verloren sind, das
er gerade gewonnen hat, für den gegenwärtigen Zweck,
was beim delphischen Wagenlenker zählt, ist
die Zurückhaltung der Figur im Moment
des Sieges oder des Ruhms eine Haltung des
Selbst  - Zurückhaltung und Selbstbeherrschung
, unterstützt durch den objektivistischen
Stil der Statue aus dem 4  80 v. Chr.
das Jahr des Beginns der zweiten
persischen Invasion und gehört zu der
kurzen Übergangszeit zwischen
spätarchaischem und frühklassischem Stil ein
auffallend schwebender Stil, der
auch durch die erhaltenen
Kulturgiebel von der Ostseite des brennenden
Tempels auf der Insel repräsentiert wird  Ägina gegenüber von
Athen zusammen mit den verbleibenden
deutlicheren Kontras aus dem
Westgiebel desselben Tempels, diese
Überreste der genetischen Murmeln,
sozusagen ein Haus in der Nähe von Münchens
anderer Antiquitätensammlung, werden die
Gruppen auch derzeit nicht öffentlich
zugänglich machen  Variation des Aufbaus des
Bildes von Kontrolle, das vor allem die Selbstkontrolle einschließt
, das von der klassischen
Skulptur im Allgemeinen und von den Beispielen
aus Delphi und Agena im Besonderen vermittelt wird, ist
geeignet, das Verhalten des
Wagenlenkers in Platons mythischer Erzählung zu visualisieren, der
gleichzeitig seine beiden Pferde kontrolliert
und vor allem beherrscht
sich der mythos als brikett
für eepa plato  Philosophischen Zwecken geht es nicht
darum, das Ziegenpferd
Prince laufen zu lassen, während das schlechte
gezügelt wird, noch geht es um den Mythos,
zwischen Pferden zu wählen und sozusagen entweder die richtige
oder die falsche Wahl unter dem
Siegerpferd zu treffen, sondern darum
, Kontrolle auszuüben und die Kontrolle zu
behalten  über den gesamten Streitwagen aufgestellt
und zu wissen, wohin es in erster
Linie geht, geht es den Maestern um die prekäre
Position des Wagenlenkers, der
sich sozusagen auf halbem Weg zwischen
Erde und Himmel zwischen der Welt der
Sinne und der Welt des Geistes befindet
und wer  braucht alle Kontrolle und
Selbstbeherrschung, die er beherrschen kann, aber
der Mythos entspricht auch dem erotischen
Subtext des gesamten Dialogs über
Selbstaufgabe im Wahnsinn,
Wahnsinn aller Art, aber im Wahnsinn der richtigen
Art, göttlicher Wahnsinn und über Kontrolle
selbst und
gerade in solchem
nn die charakterliche Kongruenz zwisc
en Platons Mythos vom Wagenlenker und e
Die griechische Streuung im 5. Jahrhundert v. Chr.
ist kein Zufall. Die Diskrepanz in der
Chronologie zwischen Platons Schriften aus dem frühen 4.
Jahrhundert und Kunstwerken aus einem
ganzen Jahrhundert zuvor spiegelt den
pointierten und leckronischen Charakter von Platons
Philosophie und Politik wider, nicht für Platon
den liberalen Individualismus des perikleischen
Athens, wie er scharfsinnig dargestellt wird
Thukydides Bericht über die frühe Phase
des Peloponnesischen Krieges mit seinen
aristokratischen Neigungen ist lacunae philia
lacht über spartanische Dinge und sein Groll, um
nicht zu sagen, Ressentiments gegen das demokratische Massen-
Athen für den Prozess und die
Hinrichtung seines Lehrers Sokrates Plato
muss als konservativer
Revolutionär im Amt gewirkt haben  -war Athen oder
sollen wir in Ethik BYE MOM
noch sagen Platons Sehnsucht nach früheren
Werten und Ansichten für das, was Hegel
griechische ethische Lebensblüher nannte
, bringt eine politisch-
philosophische Alternative zum Athener
Protoliberalismus und die Art von Freiheit
hervor, die der Freiheit unähnlich ist  der freien
Wahl ein praetor liberal fo  Der Begriff der Freiheit, der
von politischen und moralischen
Philosophen von Platon und Aristoteles geschätzt wird, um zu
jagen und zu fischen,
teilt Philosophen
und Bürger gleichermaßen mit
Freiheit oder Freiheit, die Griechen, weil
beide a la tarea sind,
könnte viele Dinge bedeuten, von denen die grundlegende Bedeutung
abgeleitet ist  die absolute Herrschaft der freien Herren
über den unfreien Sklaven der Ort
ist
doulas politisch gesprochen
frei zu sein bedeutete eher zu herrschen als beherrscht zu werden, wie
in der zerbrechlichen Freiheit der Griechen
von der persischen Herrschaft, wenn man sie auf eine
einzelne griechische Polis anwandte, bedeutete Freiheit auch
die Freiheit von  eine despotische
Herrschaft eines lokalen starken Tyrannen Transfers
von der politischen Sphäre in die des
Individuums der individuelle Mensch
Freiheitsklasse Selbstbestimmung bedeutete
, über seine Leidenschaften, Begierden und Wünsche zu herrschen,
anstatt von ihnen beherrscht zu werden Energie
zum zweifachen Politischen  Freiheit von
fremden Herrschern und von einheimischen Tyrannen
Die pseudoethische Freiheit der Selbstverwaltung
war nicht nur bei t  Die
psychoethische Freiheit oder Selbstbestimmung stand nicht nur im
Gegensatz zur Unfreiheit,
von jemand anderem regiert zu werden, sondern auch zu der Pseudofreiheit
, von den eigenen
Leidenschaften, Begierden und Begierden regiert zu werden, in einem
illusionären Szenario, heimlich
regiert zu werden, indem man sich scheinbar selbst so regiert
Wie der Fall des tyrannischen
Menschen in der psychopolitischen Pathologie,
der von Platons Republik Abschnitt zur modernen Psychopolitik bereitgestellt wird,
zitieren Sie noch einmal
diesen von Lichtenberg, pflegte er seine
oberen und unteren Seelenkräfte das
Ober- und Unterhaus und sehr oft das
erstere zu nennen  Der verabschiedete Gesetzentwurf, der
den politischen Hintergrund der
altgriechischen Bindung von Freiheit an
Selbstbeherrschung ablehnte, findet mit dem Aufkommen des modernen souveränen Territorialstaates im postfeudalen Raum eine modifizierte Fortsetzung in
modernen Freiheitskonzepten
politischer Herkunft und psychologischer
Anwendung
Europa, wie es von Jean
Bodin Thomas Hobbes als politische Herrschaft
unabhängig von seiner Erde theoretisiert wurde  In monarchischen
Zügen wird die Anfrage oder sogar demokratische Form
an die Sorge um einen Staat gebunden, der
aus Souveränen und
Untertanen wie Commonwealth und Hobbes
République besteht. In Buda besteht
die neu konzipierte und bereitgestellte
Freiheit des Bürgers, die Bürgerfreiheit, wie
Montesquieu sie nennen wird, in
Anspruchsfreiheiten  wie wir sagen zu allen
Dingen, die nicht ausdrücklich durch
das Gesetz verboten sind,
das berühmte Schweigen des Gesetzes in Hobbes, das
schließlich in der Konzeption von Preta formalisiert wurde,
positive Rechtsansprüche, natürliche
Rechte und Glück in einer damit verbundenen Entwicklung,
in einigen Ländern erwirbt die Bürgerschaft
kollektiv betrachtet Freiheit
in einer bestimmten Weise  politische im Gegensatz
zum bloß zivilen Sinn
heißt dann auch in Montesquieu durch
einen Teil der Gesetzgebung des
in England führenden Landes Freiheit, die
den doppelten Sinn
annimmt, negativ frei zu sein bzw
sich selbst Gesetze geben durch
Repräsentanten der eigenen  Die Wahl oder
zumindest die Wahl einer historisch
gesehen parlamentarischen
Repräsentation eines Wahlkreises, wie begrenzt und lässlich auch immer, stellt eine
Art modernen Nachfolger der
direktdemokratischen Selbstverwaltung im antiken Griechenland dar
und um die demokratische
Klientelpolitik im republikanischen Rom zu verklagen, die man als
überlegen und prinzipientreu gegenüber der
Antike erachtete  Sicherlich ist das moderne
System der parlamentarischen
Repräsentation in England fortgeschritten und wird in
kontinentalen republikanischen Regimen zum
Beispiel in den Niederlanden praktiziert. Der damalige General des Staates ist
typischerweise
auf die Legislative der Regierung beschränkt
und belässt die Exekutive in den Händen
eines Erben  Monarch oder ein selbst gewählter
als kradischer Körper technisch gesehen ist
die neu erworbene oder zumindest angestrebte
Freiheit keine Selbstherrschaft, sondern Selbstgesetzgebung
Autonomie im ursprünglichen
legislativen Sinne des Begriffs nur die
politischen Umwälzungen, die erstmals
Revolutionen am Ende des 18.
Jahrhunderts genannt wurden  im britischen Kolonialgebiet North
Am  erica dann im bankrotten absolutistischen
Frankreich mit unterschiedlichem Erfolg und
Dauer
Volkssouveränität und demokratische
Regierung auf ein ausgedehntes Gebiet brachten, das weit
über die engen Grenzen eines
antiken griechischen Stadtstaates hinausging
Seine
gesamte Maturitätsmoralphilosophie
zum Autonomieprinzip ist zwar das
von Kant propagierte ethische Gesetzgeben
nicht irgendein psychisches
parlamentarisches Mehrheitsentscheidungsverfahren über
von allen zu übernehmende und zu befolgende Verhaltensnormen, sondern das
Wahl- und
Auswahlverfahren des Gesetzgebungsverfahrens
[ __ ] beinhaltet die Vernunft,
die das moralische Gesetz bereitstellt, da der moralische
Akteur sich selbst das Gesetz gibt.
Ethische Autonomie ist bei Kant
kein Fall persönlicher Selbstbestimmung wie
in aktuellen Konzeptionen individueller
gesellschaftlicher oder politischer Autonomie,
sondern der Normos in Autonomie ist
Gründe an  Recht und das itas in Autonomie
Die Vernunft selbst ist bei beiden Fragen und
bestimmt das Recht der dualen formalen wie
auch der strittigen Autonomie der Vernunft
und Kants Ethik bringt den
außerordentlichen Charakter des Sittengesetzes
im Lande weit davon entfernt, einen materiellen
Höchststand und als eine antike Du-Dominus-
Ethik unter die Herrschaft zu bringen  teleologie irgendeines
höchsten guts das grundgesetz der
landesmoral ist nichts anderes als eine sehr form der
rechtmäßigkeit
anzeiger nachricht karte vermögenskonto als
sammlung bzw. die verletzung,
die ihr zugrunde liegen soll, besteht im gewillten
und der verlust minimaler bloß formaler
bedingung der universalität wie am  Ich nicht
und dies aus keinem anderen Grund, als weil das
Wollen in irgendeiner anderen Form
heteronome Faktoren beinhalten würde,
Neigungen, die die reine
Rationalität des Wollens abstrahieren und die
strenge Autonomievernunft behindern, kann frei
einräumen, dass gewöhnliches Wollen
unter im Wesentlichen schlechten
Bedingungen sowohl des Eigeninteresses als auch des Eigeninteresses stattfindet
Selbsttäuschung darüber, dass
Eigeninteressen Beteiligung noch, wenn es
Zum moralischen Charakter der
Moral des Wollens kommt all das hinzu, was aramis
Faktoren außer Acht lassen soll und die
universelle Form des Wollens alles ist, worauf es
in seiner späten quasi materiellen
Ethik unter dem Deckmantel einer
Tugendlehre im zweiten Teil der Metaphysik der
Moral 1797 ankommen kann  Nicht einmal die
früher festgestellte Autonomie des
ethischen Wollens wird durch das, was er
die Autokratie der ethischen Vernunft in der Willensbestimmung nennt,
bereichert  Vernunft liegt in der
gewöhnten Fähigkeit, das
Moralgesetz der Vernunft gegen den kultivierenden
Einfluss der Neigungen zu erlassen, die nach dem
Vorbild der politischen Funktion der
Exekutive für Kant die antike
Charakteranlage der Exzellenz
pflegen, reduziert sich rational zur Tugend des Nichtstuns wie der eifrig kultivierte Hang zum
Handeln Sie nach dem moralischen Gesetz und
weil es das moralische Gesetz ist und nicht
fo  Aus anderen egoistischen Gründen oder
gar entgegen der moralischen
Differenz zwischen Platons im
Grunde altertümlicher Vorstellung von der
rationalen Selbstherrschaft der Seelen und der
entschieden modernen Vorstellung des autonomen
und autokratisch rationalen
Wollens stimmen Planer und Widerlegungen ungeachtet des Ethos der Selbstbeherrschung überein
und Selbstdisziplin,
die ein Menschenleben durchdringen soll, das es wert ist
, frei genannt zu werden, aber für Kant reicht bloße
Selbstbeherrschung oder gar Selbstbeherrschung mit rationalen
Mitteln nicht aus, um
ethisch sinnvolle Freiheit zu gewährleisten, denn es
gibt ein Spiegelbild, das nicht
selten ist  Fall der eigenen
Sensibilität, die ihre Rationalität
in den Dienst zwingt
, ist die instrumentalisierende Vernunft, die
auf eine Art Selbstzwang hinausläuft, Schritte, die
man nennen kann, die im Wesentlichen
unfrei sind
Allein die
einschränkende Sensibilität unabhängig von
sensorischen Einflüssen kann co sein
Als echter oder, wie Kant es explizit nennt,
freier Selbstzwang
gilt, dass in der späten Metaphysik der
Moral im Gegensatz zu Platons im Wesentlichen antikem Selbstzwang ethischer Selbstzwang und
freier Surfzwang zusammenfallen und umgekehrt
der eigentliche Begriff der
Selbstbeherrschung  schließt eine beherrschende Rolle
der Sinneswünsche oder Begierden aus,
da Menschen von Natur aus ihre
eigene Natur sind, entweder so, dass sie
herrschen oder beherrscht werden sollen
, und in dieser Hinsicht keiner Wahl und Änderung unterworfen sind
, um die Angelegenheit in Begriffen zu bringen  Die
Beziehung, die allem antiken
griechischen Denken über Freiheit und Freiheit zugrunde
liegt, das Sinnliche ist der natürliche Sklave, wie
ihm zu Grunde liegt, nun zur modernen
Sinnlichkeit die explizite Versklavung
der Sinne nicht nur versäumt,
den echten Beitrag der Sinnlichkeit
zur Ökonomie des Geistes anzuerkennen
akademisch festgestellt von
Baumgarten in seiner Emanzipation der
Ästhetik von der Logik für einige moderne
Denker suc  h als Hume die alte
Sichtweise auch Fehler darin versäumt hat,
die wesentliche und
Sklavenposition der Vernunft zu erkennen, beides, der
Geduldsklave der Geduld, um sicher zu sein
, kann nicht die
sentimentalistische und methodische
Einschätzung der Gründe Saurus des peruanischen
Trolls auf der Seite vergessen  Land nach Khans
überlegter Darstellung in der
Kritik der praktischen Vernunft Vernunft ist
nicht nur in der Lage, das Wollen zu motivieren, sondern
es ganz von selbst ausreichend zu motivieren,
wie sich in der berühmten oder eher
berüchtigten Tatsache
offenbart, als das unmittelbar
sichere und praktisch wirksame
Bewusstsein von verstanden zu werden  der unbedingten moralischen
sicherheitspflicht [ __ ] selbst hatte in der, wie er es nannte, scherzhaften PMD-
Etikette Jonas in Bezug auf die
Kraft, die dem tatsächlichen Vollzug des
moralischen Wollens zugrunde liegt, allenfalls die Kriterien für die Beurteilung der Moral des Wollens und Handelns zur Vernunft gebracht  und Schauspielerei, aber halte ihn
aktiv mit der Verpflichtung, ein Gefühl zu sein, das so
ein Ge ist  Nerous ein moralisches Gefühl in den 1780er Jahren,
obwohl es nicht zu einer vernünftigeren,
genauer
praktischen, gut bestimmenden Vernunft kommen und ihr vertrauen kann, mit
ausreichender Zugkraft, um eine
vollständige Beziehung und die daraus resultierende Handlung zu erzeugen
, die dies tatsächlich den seltenen
Fall der Sonne darstellt rein  die Vernunft, die
von sich aus praktisch
ist, reine praktische Vernunft oder hat sie manchmal
praktische Theorien genannt, das vom kritischen Kant behauptete hinreichend
motivierende Potential der praktischen Vernunft
ist
vielen als billige Lösung in der
Art eines deus ex machina erschienen, auf das ein göttlicher
Apparat auf wundersame Weise aufgesetzt wurde  Die
Theater des modernen Geistes, die aus dem Nichts kommen
und eine dramatische Lösung bieten, die
zwar unterhalten, aber ihren Gesang nicht befriedigen kann, müssen
der Interaktion rein
praktischer Vernunft als
einzige Option in einem Szenario erschienen sein,
das die Moral des Gefühls der
Briten, hauptsächlich Schotten, ausschloss  Moralisten und
die perfektionistische moralische Teleologie einer
Ethik von im Wesentlichen tourett  Die
theoretische, rein kognitive Vernunft,
die von kontinentalen Rationalisten vertreten wird, glaubt
jedoch, die
platonische Lösung für die ethische
Unwirksamkeit, die meine Vernunft bedroht, übersehen zu haben,
die darin besteht, auf eine
Kraft oder Quelle zurückzugreifen, die sich sowohl vom
rationalen Denken als auch von den irrationalen
Begierden unterscheidet, die eine sein können  gemacht
, um der Vernunft
bei der Kopfsalatbemühung zu helfen, das Irrationale zu unterdrücken,
ähnlich wie ein General
eine Armee einsetzt, um den Feind zu bekämpfen, aber was die
alten Neigungen angeht, war Kant weder ein
Kenner noch ein Anhänger von Platons unserer
sokratisch geneigten moralischen Psychologie und
Ethik in dem Maße, dass  der ethische
formalistische Rationalismus
, der Kant erlaubte oder sogar erforderte, war neostoisch oder vielmehr
ein neuer, neuer Stoiker, der vom
Stoizismus der lateinischen Sprache der späten römischen Kaiserzeit beeinflusst wurde,
wie Xenakis, der
die Beherrschung aller Patienten lehrt und praktiziert,
einschließlich solcher potenter
Motivatoren des Privaten und Politischen
Aktion als Wut ja, um zu
etablieren und zu pflegen  Ich bin eine gelassene Denkweise,
danke Liter Feind der stoischen Sensibilitäten von Kansas,
platonische GVO mit dieser
Verbindung von Tugend und Männlichkeit, wie auch
vermittelt, pala let invert Fötus
wäre ein höchst unzuverlässiger erschienen und ich
neige dazu, mich gegen die Vernunft zu wenden
und sein eigenes kriegerisches und männliches
Regime zu etablieren  wurde einem von Kens
engsten Nachfolgern überlassen, eine
Variation des platonischen Themas der
Seelen zu Pferd Shariat zu liefern, obwohl sie
nicht von einem alten Bild aus der Kriegsführung und dem
Wettkampfsport, sondern von einer modernen
Vorstellung von der treibenden Kraft hinter den
verschiedenen Phänomenen des Lebens geprägt war
Lebewesen Der von Karl eingeführte Begriff
des Triebtyps hatte in der philosophischen Psychologie einen hohen Stellenwert, hatte in
jüngster Zeit eine kurze
Geschichte in der werdenden Biologie, wo er dazu
diente, die Dispositionen zur
Gestaltung eines Lebewesens in Bezug
auf die Buchstaben Teile Organe und
Gesamtorganismus Hauptvertreter zu bezeichnen  der
Diskurs eines Laufwerks war der Wächter
Arzt Physiologe yo und der törichte
Buddha, der sou hatte  Der Versuch,
Entstehung und Wachstum lebender Organismen auf
einen zugrunde liegenden Gestaltungstrieb des jungen
Schlafs zurückzuführen, der weniger einem
neu entdeckten Manifest
tierischen Lebens dienen sollte, als vielmehr einer erklärenden
Hypothese ihrer Gesamtorganisation
und Lebensdynamik, kann sich schon nicht
belegen lassen, akzeptierte Li  Bloomers
Deutungsapparat des formenden Triebs
in der philosophischen Biologie, der
den Kern des zweiten Teils der Kritik
der Urteilskraft bildete, war es jedoch Carlina
Reinhard, die den Begriff des Triebs aus dem Natürlichen und dem zweiten Band
seiner Briefe zur Kantischen Philosophie
1792 importierte
Philosophie in die Moralphilosophie
Der Brief, der weithin so konzipiert ist, dass er sowohl
den Geist als auch die Moral umfasst, Gewaltbriefe,
insbesondere der zweite Teil
, der den Fokus von der ersten auf
die zweite Kritik verlagert, kombiniert
einführende und erklärende Ziele mit
Versuchen, wenn nicht die
Substanz, so doch zumindest die Präsentation zu überarbeiten
Form
- Tell'em Afghanen akademisch informierter
Philosoph  hy im Interesse größerer
Popularität und breiterer Akzeptanz in
Briefen, wo keine Substitute sind,
beginnt die kantische duale Disposition der Fakultät des Begehrens von Bergen,
die ich den Brief in ein höheres
vernunftbeherrschtes und das niedrigere rein
imperative Register mit einer Dualität von
Trieben unterteilt habe  jeder identifiziert sich durch seine
Beziehung zum Selbst, während beide
von Reinhold
in leo unterschiedenen Triebe der höheren und niederen Formen des
Begehrens sich auf das Selbst beziehen, das sie
sind und wen sie anstreben, um
die beiden im Wesentlichen beide Selbst in Aktion zu treiben oder in Aktion zu bewegen
-dienende Triebe werden
unterschieden in egoistisch egoistisch und
selbstlos selbstlos respektive
Underground's Sichtweise ist die Selbstachtung
dort definierend für eine lebende
Wesensaussicht und Öffentlichkeitsarbeit manifestiert sich in
zwei Formen als egoistische Selbstachtung
eng fokussiert auf egoistische Ziele und
Ziele und als selbstlose Selbstachtung
großzügig erhalten  lehrte einen
Campus in der Konzeption des Selbst, ähnlich der
altgriechischen Tugend von m  Gelassenheit
angesichts der beiden Arten von Verlangen, die
als zwei gegensätzliche Triebe rekonfiguriert werden, muss der
Rheinhalogenagent, der so zwischen
gegensätzlichen Trieben schwebt, wählen, welchen von
ihnen er befriedigen möchte, wobei der Prozess der
Entscheidung unter ihnen eine
Ausübung der freien Wahl darstellt, die
weder von der Polizei noch von der Wilco-Leinwand überzeugt ist  Die von
Reynolds angebliche Besserung, die Sie
eher als verschlimmernd denn als verbessernd hüteten,
insbesondere Penn wendet sich gegen die Parität
zwischen egoistischem und selbstlosem
Streben in Bezug auf eine Wahl, die
von der Vernunft geleitet wird, um eine
Übung in willkürlicher Wahl zu sein,
kann dies im Übrigen leugnen  die vermeintliche
Fähigkeit oder Fähigkeit Mitmensch,
dem egoistischen Trieb zu folgen und damit
gegen das Sittengesetz zu handeln, konnte durchaus
als positive Potentialität
angesehen werden, ja nach Kant war sie sogar als die ganz
negative Unfähigkeit der Nicht-
Fähigkeit zu folgen anzusehen  das Sittengesetz
in gleicher Weise für Kant die angebliche
Freiheit zu lassen  Sich vom
selbstsüchtigen Trieb treiben zu lassen, stellte ein Versagen der
Freiheit dar, und das Fehlen eines wirklich freien,
autonomen Willens Plato hätte
Khans Bedenken geteilt, als er sah, wie sein
pferdegetriebener, von Pferden gezogener Streitwagen
durch ein Duo aus gegensätzlichen Trieben und
dem rationalen Wagenlenker ersetzt wurde, der nach Gewinn strebte
und die Kontrolle über das gesamte System behalten, das
gegen einen willkürlich wählenden Antriebswähler ausgetauscht wird,
als ob die Antriebe
echte alternative Modi für die
Fahrzeugbewegung wären, insbesondere Plato
hätte Einwände gegen die Vorstellung erhoben,
dass die Alternative zwischen der egoistischen
und der selbstlosen Antriebskraft
wirklich war  offen und die Wahl zwischen den
beiden willkürlich frei und gleich
aus platonischer Sicht im Wesentlichen
geteilt von Can't Pry Notes Die
freie Wahl unter den polnischen Trieben verwechselt
die edle Freiheit, die darin besteht,
die Vernunft anzuerkennen und zu befolgen, und
die grundlegende Freiheit, zu tun, was einem gefällt,
egal  was die Gründe und
Folgen einer solchen silbernen liberalen
Lizenz
sind  l Scheinbar weg von [ __ ]
und Plato,
aber Vater, aber ich bemerke, dass Fisch
immer noch die Disco der Triebe fortsetzt,
die in der postkantianischen
Philosophie eingeführt wurden, indem er
die nicht abfangende
positive ethisch erforderliche Freiheit beibehält, anstatt sie zu ignorieren,
um mit fünfzig zu beginnen, die den Reinhold ersetzt
en Dualismus des egoistischen und des
uneigennützigen Triebs mit der Unterscheidung
zwischen dem natürlichen und dem reinen Trieb
bedeutete dies eine bessere Erfassung Kansas
Unterscheidung zwischen den niederen und den
höheren Begierdesfähigkeiten insbesondere
fünfzig begreift den reinen Trieb als das
innewohnende Streben nach Freiheit  um ihrer
selbst willen, die damit im rahmen seiner postkantianischen transzendentalphilosophie das letzte
wie höchste ziel menschlichen
strebens bildet, versteht herrin lira v freiheit als
unabhängigkeit von allem fremden und
fremden im interesse der reinen
selbstidentität oder
demgegenüber IO  Der natürliche Drang nach Vista
beinhaltet das Streben nach materiellen Zwecken
aller Art nebst den Mitteln zu ihrer
Erreichung die jeweiligen Zwecke und
die geeigneten Mittel durch die
Natur der Dinge gegeben sind, durch die natürlich
gegebene Stellung des jeweiligen einzelnen Menschen
, aber auch durch die
natürlichen Lebensumstände, die
diese fortan festgelegt haben  Ausblick Die beiden Triebe sind
nicht so sehr gegensätzlich, als
dass sie die verschiedenen
Seiten des Menschen darstellen, der zugleich
endlich und unendlich sinnlich,
tierisch und göttliche
Organe ist, proto eigentlich
zentralistische CEO-Anthropologie der strebenden
Subjektivität entsprechend der
Gesamtstrategie der Ausblicke  Die Neukonzeptualisierung
von Conti und praktischer Psychologie ist
integrativ und versöhnend bis zu dem
Punkt, an dem sie sich die Verschmelzung des
künstlich abstrahierten reinen Triebs und
des ebenso abstrakten natürlichen Triebs mit
dem Konkreten vorstellt, das als Go-Trieb auf
Gesichtern
versöhnt wird  ende ein
ultimativ unendliches ende aus dem reinen
antrieb  e, das auf nichts als absolute
Unabhängigkeit und seine dazwischen liegenden
ganz endlichen Ziele vom natürlichen
Trieb abzielt, der die Anforderungen
der begrenzten Reife darstellt, manifestieren Aspekte der
menschlichen Existenz, für die die
Diffusion des materiellen natürlichen Triebs und des
formalen reinen Triebs zur
Serialisierung führt  Menschliches Handeln in jedem
Moment soll das menschliche Handelnde so handeln
, dass das Begrenzte und Streben unter
den Umständen zu einer
ganzen konsistenten Reihe beiträgt, deren unendlich
entfernter Endpunkt die
absolute Freiheit ist, deren Einzelheiten
diese Vision die moralische Ordnung darstellt
auf so viele unterschiedliche Weisen durch mehrere
parallele Serien angegangen werden, an denen unterschiedliche
individuelle Agenturen beteiligt sind, bleibt weitgehend
unklar, selbst ein Adressmerkmal scheint
eine Art vorab festgelegter Harmonie
zwischen den parallelen Serien anzunehmen, in dem
gemeinsamen Bemühen, vollständige
Unabhängigkeit zum Preis der völligen
Identität zwischen ihnen herzustellen  Natürlich vielfältige
Agenten perfektionieren die Ethik von abso  Laute
Freiheitskabinette mehr in der Vorhersage
als in der Vorschrift, dass letztlich
jedes ethische Wesen gleich handeln wird,
weil alle ethischen Wesen zwar gleich sind
, aber das
postindividualistische Szenario der
absoluten ethischen Identität bleibt ein
entferntes und immer zu erreichendes und
niemals zu seindes  erreicht, aber es spiegelt eine
politisch-philosophische Denkweise wider,
die totale Freiheit mit totaler
Identität gleichsetzt Identität mit sich selbst
sowie mit allen anderen auf Kosten von
Unterschiedlichkeit und Vielfalt auf
individueller und sozialer Ebene
Universalität des Sittengesetzes mit der
pseudoethischen zutiefst politischen
Forderung eines Verhaltenskommentars aller
Kantischer Protoliberalismus ist
in einer verwandten Entwicklung auf 15 Protosozialismus umgestellt worden
Merkmale Ethik
Entschuldigung Rückgriff auf das Rationalitätsgetriebe
Gerät des kategorischen Imperativs
statt stützender moralischer Selbstbewertung
und andere unter dem Vorwurf  d und
irrende Gewissensstimme entstanden mit dem
aus der Fünfzigerjahre-Ethik entfernten prozessualen Rationalitätsgebot Die
Orientierung Die orientierende wie auch die
motivierende Kraft des Handelns liegt
ganz in den Trieben, in der
durch den reinen Trieb gegebenen Gesamtorientierung
und in dem Anstoß zum einzelnen C
wirklich  geeignete handlungen gefördert durch den
natürlichen antrieb bleibt
dem ehemaligen lenker des fahrers platon
nur noch die sorgfältige koordinierung des
kurzfristigen und des langfristigen antriebs, die
den wagen zuerst für sich und dann gemeinsam mit wenig
lenk- oder führungsbedarf antreiben  ein teil des
fahrers, der in platons Invictus eher ein beifahrer als ein wagenlenker ist, ist jetzt ein
identitätsfixiertes psychomobil. die
freiheit, die mit den gesichtern nach der
kantischen rückeroberung auf dem wagen der seele einhergeht,
ist gleichzeitig
groß und klein, sie besteht materiell
im gesuchten  aber tatsächlich
unerreichbare absolute Freiheit von völliger
Unabhängigkeit und vollständiger Selbstidentität
und formal  in der Freiheit von der
Notwendigkeit durch irgendeinen
Antrieb, der nicht
in das serielle Gesamtszenario des
ethischen Fortschritts passt, wobei das Kantonsrecht
durch das Postulat der schieren
Selbstidentität und Kanton durch eine
praktische Vernunft durch die
kantische Gewissensstimme ersetzt wird  autonome und/oder
toccatas Freiheitsinitiative Freiheit
nach einem selbst gegebenen Gesetz
erhält bei Fisher ebenfalls einen radikalen Ersatz,
sie reduziert sich auf die etwas zeremonielle
Funktion, dem zuzustimmen oder abzulehnen,
was der zusammengesetzte Charakter des Verstandes
der gemischte Trieb aufgrund einer
abfälligen Bemerkung fordert  über die freiheit eines
mit einer mechanischen wende
aufgezogenen spießes und seiner bartonverkäufer in der
zweiten kritik könnte man diese 54
mit freiheit die
freiheit des
räuberstempels nennen im blick zurück über vista und reinhold
zu platon scheint das die uralte
funktion zu sein  der Wagenlenker ist obsolet geworden,
die moderne Seele erscheint
weitgehend von Trieben bewegt  verschiedene
Arten, die für den verbleibenden Fahrer auf dem Streitwagen kaum etwas anderes zu tun haben
, als auf
konkurrierende widersprüchliche und sich verschmelzende
Triebe zu reagieren, entspricht es völlig dieser
Übernahme des Streitwagens durch die Pferde,
wenn Freud knapp ein Jahrhundert
nach Reinhold erklärt und feststellt, dass die
rational freie selbst das auge ist nicht der
herr im eigenen haus
mit dieser nüchternen beurteilung hätte Kant dem anderen zugestimmt,
angesichts der realistischen um nicht zu sagen
pessimistischen
anthropologie, die das gegenteil
seiner idealistischen ethik der rational freien
autonomie den erhabenen gedanken des vernunftwesens bildet
von sich aus praktisch und daher
ausreichend, um den Willen zu bestimmen,
scheint eine große Geschichte geworden zu sein, aber im Gegensatz zu
Platons erhebendem Mythos von der
Nächstenliebe der Seele danke